I'm gonna take a moment getting around
to the answer to this question because
there's so many different mistakes one
can make right here let's explore some
of the incorrect options before we
arrive at the right answer a simple idea
might be to repeat the code that we saw
in the car function right here in the
van subclass constructor since there's
so little of it
notice this would have the effect of
creating a local property on every
instance and that local property would
point to the number in question but
that's not exactly what we want if it
forces us to repeat the same code in two
different places but this poses a few
issues for one if you ever change how
instantiation works you would have to
remember to change both places
furthermore you can tell that the logic
here is quite simple but that's just for
the purpose of our example in most
classes there's going to be a lot more
code in the superclass constructor that
you would have to repeat in the subclass
so we have a bit of a puzzle on our
hands
we'd really like to simply run the car
function in the middle of the van
function but in such a way that it
modifies the new van instance that's
being created you might suppose we could
simply call car the way you normally do
with the keyword new in front of it but
this is problematic for a couple of
reasons what would you expect the effect
of this technique to be on your
in-memory model take a moment to imagine
how this code would play out when it's
actually running for reference here is
the in-memory model that we're starting
to build up the answer is that if we try
to call the car function with the
keyword new it's gonna have the effect
of creating another new instance object
in addition to the one that got created
in run j/s as a result of calling new
van